We're heading for Shikoku once again.
This time, we're taking a Chinese flight bound for Beijing that stops in Shikoku.
So instead of getting off at Tokushima, we will stop at Takamatsu this time.
It is a little bit cheaper but we have to go all the way to Narita to take that plane.
So that's a new way for us, we are trying every available option to get there, none of them easy.
What is the meaning of "Aiki" in Aiki-jujutsu?
Aiki is the way to express Kokyu.
So Kokyu-ho means that through our Kokyu [breath], we can direct the kokyu of someone else right?
Yes, the partner breathes out "To".
Humans ventilate via inspiration and expiration, which of these is the most vulnerable phase?
Inspiration is the weak phase.
We are strong when we breathe out.
In "Aiki", there is "Ki"
It means that during Kokyu, we will use the Ki of inspiration and the Ki of expiration.
The opponent's breathing.
Does it mean that we can steal the "Iki" [vitality] of the partner?
Yes, that too.
The opponent is then devoid of his Iki.
Yes, that is right.
It is the effect of surprise.
It is like when you point with the finger,
We usually inspire from the nose and we expire from the mouth,
but when we run a 1000m, we usually inspire and expire through the mouth
This is what comes into play in Aiki.
We use that all the time.
We often see that in Daito-ryu, for example during demonstrations.
During a movement, we reach a state of unbalance, where the tensions are stopped, a state where "Iki" is stopped.
This is what we call "Zanshin" [litterally: "the remaining spirit"].
Oh, in that sense?
This is because there is always the possibility of a counter attack.
There is also the case of "Tasu-dori", when several people come to attack at once.
In this case, we must take a guard straight away before the next person arrives from behind or who knows where.
So we usually head towards the opponent in order to protect ourselves from him.
That is the original meaning of Zanshin.
If you look somewhere else, it is not good because if someone else comes to attack, you don't see anything.
If I look at you, my field of view covers about 180 degrees, which means I can see on the sides too.
So if an attack is coming from the side, I can perceive it.
This is real Kokyu, and if you did not have that...
During training, we mainly work on grabs but in reality, we are separated from the opponent and it is at the moment when the attack arrives that we do the technique.
On Ikkajo and Nikajo, we practice on grabs, but starting from Sankajo, we start working on intention.
Yes, we allow ourselves to be grabbed, these are the fixed Kata forms.
So we study and memorize forms, and little by little, we move away from the hands that grab in these forms.
Then we switch to 2 or 3 opponents and learn to work in these conditions.
We learn to be grabbed, we learn to throw etc.
We learn to deal with these sorts of attacks in an Aiki perspective.
So the training becomes more and more vast.
Actually, the human being does not need to be taught that, it knows how to do it instinctively.
This is "Hon-no", the instinct of Aiki.
The one who dodges like that can avoid threats.
It is the same for animals, like cats right?
Yes
Humans belong to the animal kingdom, and animals have instincts.
In Aiki, this instinct is the Ki.
But this does not show during training right?
Of course it does! If it didn't, we could not do it.
I will show you tomorrow.
The next question is: "In which sense was the word "Aiki" used in the old times?"
We just spoke about that right?
It is hard to know what people were feeling in the ancient times.
Yes, during the warring states period, it must have been very different, and then different again in the Edo period.
It is difficult to compare the sword work of old Budo with today's techniques that make use of riffles or missiles.
It was very different in terms of distance for example.
It is a problem of period.
Now there are riffles but before there were bows and arrows.
When we invented the bow and arrows, we had to invent the armor to protect against them.
The problem was to figure out how to reach a man when he was mounted on a horse.
Shooting at him was useless because he had a scale armor, arrows couldn't get through.
However, you could shoot at the horse; that would work,
the horse would fall.
So the problematic is that of weaponry right?
Yes, Aiki developed according to that.
Can we find the concept of "Aiki" in other Budo than Aikido and Daito-ryu?
Of course,
It is a problem of period but Aiki is really present.
These days we talk more in terms of Kokyu and breathing.
The Kiai in Kendo is the same thing.
The fact of getting out of the way is Aiki.
Of course, in Kendo nowadays, we mainly notice the speed.
This hand motion, for example, is typical of the current times.
But this is only because we use Shinai [bamboo sticks] that you can do that.
Before, with a real sword, you could not fool around like that.
So you would not point towards the other, the sword would be used in a more vertical manner, with a high guard, so that you could "give it back" [in the sense of Kokyu described before].
This is why we used to train with big logs of wood, because it did not last a minute, but 2 or 3.
This is why the high "Hasso-kamae"-type guards were invented.
The techniques of Sankajo and Yonkajo come from there.
These movements are the reflection of these guards.
And this is how you control the other.
We control in synergy the wrists, the elbow, and the bone structure of the shoulder.
These are the techniques beyond Sankajo.
They must be seen as sword techniques.
Yes.
Style is not what matters, the content is important.
It is not because you imitate the form that it is good.
If you don't understand the essence, it is not good.
If you don't lock the movement, you get hit.
This is "Kaeshi-waza" [counter techniques], this is Aiki.
People think that Aiki is a technique of "doing",
but if there is a technique, Ura is the throw back of that technique.
"Kaeshi", "to give back", is really the Ura of that technique,
and Aiki is the Ura of a technique.
If you know how to do Sankajo, then you can do that.
Before we did not give Sandan [level sanctionign the knowledge of Sankajo] as easily and openly as that.
Nowadays, everybody gets to 7th of 8th Dan.
There used to be "Chuden" [advanced techniques] and "Okuden" [inner techniques].
This is a fundamental change.
We used to say "Chuden will be unveiled but the secrets [Okuden] will be well kept".
It was a bit different wasn't it?